so I am here after lunch so you're
either gonna fall asleep which I hope
doesn't happen but now seriously so I'm
here okay I am here to talk to you about
api's a couple of speakers this
morning's talked about api's Rafi spoke
about api's this morning
he's a he's actually in a meeting up at
the Georgetown business school right now
a couple other people mentioned
different api's what I am going what I
am here to do today is to show you how
to interface how to use our to interface
with different kinds of API well not
different kinds but to interface with
api's mostly for the consumption of data
for the consumption and or command and
control of resources that you you that
you connect to so someone was asking me
earlier about Plummer so if you don't
know about plumber plumber as a package
that allows you to build api's from the
our side and serve them we're not
talking about plumber we're talking
about the consumption of api's and and
how to use our to do that okay a couple
of things so first of all I wear many
hats my work hat is Microsoft I work for
the Microsoft Azure team I'm a cloud
solutions architect I've been with the
team for about two years I work with the
federal government and actually some of
my customers are here and I help them
transition into Azure so work with them
side by side help them come into Azure
teach them work with them etc I teach
here Georgetown as well I'm an adjunct
faculty in the analytics program and
actually many of our my students are
here so hi thanks for coming then you
know DC - DC - and the meetup stuff so
I've been involved at the community for
a long time that leaves a little time
for other stuff but anyway my this is
really talk about my personal opinions
non-acidic not Affiliate to anybody else
we're gonna start with a primer on api's
and I'm gonna give you a quick walk
through through this because I'm pretty
sure that most of you if not all of you
have at some point or not interface with
a
the ice you may not know that you're
actually interfacing with an API but
what is an API just like this big three
letters so API stands for application
programming interface what does that
really mean
it means that it's just a way for two
different systems to talk to one another
so it's you know it's it's a connector
between system a and system B that
exposes some kind of port or connection
or object and then you can actually talk
to it via many ways there's many kinds
of api's there's open api's there's
partner api's which are I guess sort of
you know private to some extent internal
API is our API is there perhaps used
internally in an organization i've not
exposed composite api's are kind of a
mix but our focus today is really on web
api's which is probably what you are
most used to now when you're using your
phone like your iPhone or the Android
phone like a lot of the stuff that
you're actually doing it's actually
calling API is these are internal API is
that you don't know that you're talking
to but the software is actually talking
to the cell providers API whatever the
applications are using the the OS api's
for doing sort of course or kinds of
things you know it's again it's this
idea that two different systems talk to
one another when we talk about API is I
think collectively as a community most
likely we're talking about web api's so
these are api's that are from platform
so you know things come to mind like
Facebook API Twitter API Meetup API I
mean the list goes on and on and on and
on so that's really the focus today
these are web api s-- why you know these
are api is where the communication
between these two systems usually
happens over the internet whether it's
public or VPN or whatever but it happens
over the internet many are open you know
the fact that you can actually connect
to a system without any form of
authentication or authorization however
many of those still open api's they've
open in the sense that they're exposed
still require authentication or
authorization so for example you know if
you want to do something with your
account there's stuff that you can
access publicly but there are things
where you actually need to authenticate
and I'm going to show you an example
they communicate using the HTTP protocol
right which is the ubiquitous web
protocol that's really what it is and
the APS that were that I'm going to talk
about today are really this this thing
called the rest api s-- well what the
heck is REST API representational state
transfer that's a mouthful that's really
an architecture now again from your
perspective this may not necessarily
matter too much but I'm just telling you
because I think it's just useful to know
what's happening and this is really are
an architecture that meets that has to
meet these six criteria so first of all
client-server separation there's a
client there's a server or system a
system a bla bla bla the second one is
really important statelessness the idea
of statelessness is that when your
interface with api is you know you have
to execute an instruction that that is
self-contained that instruction needs to
tell the receiving system what to do and
it needs to have all of the information
usually these if-then I PI you know we
can have a whole discussion on API
design that's not we're gonna do but if
an API is well designed those calls are
what's called it impotent which means
that they're stateless you know that if
you call it multiple times if you call
it once and it does what it needs to do
and then you call it a second time it's
important so it's not gonna change you
know so it so this is really important
and then these are just different
characteristics about restful api so how
does this stuff work well you know again
you have your clients here on the
left-hand side that are executing some
kind of HTTP call against the API that
there's the REST API in the middle and
then that REST API is usually it's this
interface layer right that goes ahead
internally and does something so it
could be a database access you know it
could be a platform application whatever
it is but that API what the API does is
it it it exists it that's what I'm
looking for
it abstract the exposure of the back-end
system and makes it generally accessible
to you
these are the verbs so HTTP if you don't
know uses there's kind of when you when
you navigate in your web browser and you
go to a URL that's what's called a get
call or it's it's a get it's a method
it's again which means just retrieve
retrieve an object right from somewhere
now again API is usually have a URL
associated with them that hopefully is
accessible openly via the Internet but
these are these are the six main verbs
so you have post get patch put should
put twice delete so usually you're doing
again again is retrieving information so
after the end of my talk what I'm hoping
you'll be able to do is use a couple of
our packages to go and get stuff from
the web that you would normally go and
point click and download or execute
stuff as well the other two important
verbs to know about our post and put so
post is to submit something right
posting is you're taking something from
your local machine or your local client
and you're pushing it to the API so that
the API knows what to do with it and
then a put is something that gets I
think it's changed so we're I'm gonna
show you an example of a get and a post
which are probably the two most
important things that you'll be working
with this is how api's work really right
so here's your consumer so you know when
you issue the API call again all of
information is self-contained the API
you issue the API call the API receives
your call and this says hey can I have
XYZ and the API shuttles that
information and makes it do whatever it
needs to do you know again this is kind
of an it does it via the get command
there's usually a URL with a path you've
seen these right exposed but even when
you navigate the web or URLs and then
the API returns something and that
something is made up of a header which
includes a response a status code and
the HTTP response and that returns back
to the consumer and pretty simple this
is what a URL you know this is what uh
what a API call usually looks like right
so you've got the method are actually
the the request URL this could be really
nested some
times you have like you have a think of
it like a main URL and then forward
slash different types of activities like
whether it's you know for example the
meetup API you can do like events you
can do members you can do and and each
of them has a different functionality
now it's up to the API designers to
design it well again you've got the
header the body so when you're when you
are getting something a get call so by
definition a get call is just to
retrieve something and common HTTP
calling your browsers just to get call
there's other tools that we're gonna
talk about today but then there's all
this other metadata and the body of your
of your API call well how does my day to
come back who knows what this is
hmm yep
so most modern web api's are designed to
work with JSON objects and if you're not
familiar with JSON object JSON object
I think the jas comes from JavaScript it
is not really JavaScript but it takes
that sort of idea of key value pairs
that starts with a curly brace and then
you know you can have actually you have
a key and then a value this is an array
you can just have keys and values as
text and but it starts and ends with a
curly brace when you submit an API call
most likely you're going to submit some
kind of JSON object and what you get
back is going to be some kind of JSON
object so here's what we're gonna do
this is my github repository page right
so when I navigate to my github repo and
again I'm logged in but if you go to my
github repository page you're probably
gonna see most of these I think most of
these are public so we're gonna create a
github repo in two different ways first
of all I'm gonna use Curl Curl is a
command line tool that invokes a library
called lip curl which is a sea library
and then I'm gonna show you how to do
that with our okay so rather than going
to the web and pointing and clicking and
whatnot I am issuing a curl so this is
the API call right so when I do curl
that's actually retrieving my
repositories so it's just querying me as
a user and it's returning this JSON
object with actually this is not about
my user information
there's a lot more here but this is what
a JSON object looks like it's just it's
just plain text this here is the same
call but now I'd add an eye which just
means return the header the header
contains a lot of metadata this first
one here is the most probably one of the
most important things to know which is
your status code it's gonna tell you
whether you're a PL API call was
successful or not
so the famous 404 actually this popular
mechanics has an article that came out
earlier this week it talks about the 404
error and its history and it's actually
I didn't read through it but it comes
from printing I don't know I didn't it's
a really important trade but one of the
things you get back is an HTTP code you
know 200 fit was successful 201 if you
did a put and it was successful
404 if the resource was not found' so
you guys are familiar with that this is
a this is an example of an authenticated
post so now in this case in previous
ones I did curl I didn't have the dash X
which means but by default is again
right it's to retrieve an object this is
actually a post now there is redundant
information in this call because I'm
saying post now here I'm actually
authenticating right so I actually have
a personal personal API key in my
account but and then as you see here the
D I am actually submitting a JSON object
that's part of my API call so I'm
actually invoking the github API to
create a repository it's just going to
create an empty repo now when I run this
I didn't get the header back but you got
a 201 I think a 201 which means the the
post is successful and then you get a
bunch of metadata about your repository
so this is a screenshot but that repo
was created in my github account via the
command line right okay well great
that's all great now that's its curl
that's the key Melanie well so what well
let me show you how to do this with art
so there are three packages that you
probably want to be familiar with okay
the first one is HTT our it's part of
the tidy verse written by Hadley Wickham
enough said the second one is curl this
is actually a fairly new package it's
called curl and like the curl command
line option you know both of these
actually still use that lib curl under
the hood so if you're most like if
you're in a linux machine curl is
probably installed if you're in a map
you have to install curl you need the
curl library for this stuff to work if
you're a Windows everything gets
installed automatically but you still
need to have curl onto a hood and then
the last one is json light json light is
a really really lightweight package that
converts lists to json and json to lists
and and vice versa
both of these packages are actually
calling json light under the hood even
if you're not aware about now you can
use JSON light individually there used
to be another package called our curl
but this suite was from a from xur own
he is actually the creator and he does
like telling people like that's old
don't look at it use use the new package
which is called curl and and they they
work pretty well now if we go back to
the previous slide you know this says
here that for a more user friendly HTTP
client look at the HTT r package so
you're really for attr it actually
obstructs a lot of this stuff it makes
it very easy curl is a little bit more
complicated you do have to have I think
a better understanding of the headers
and all these sorts of things I haven't
even talked about authentication which
is a whole other other topic internet
itself so this was the command line yeah
this is the this is the call that we did
before right I created so I'm doing a
post this was the command line this is
how you would do it in our so I first I
specify the end point right these are
just different three different strings
that I declared here I'm actually
defining the body of my of my of my call
but I'm just I'm creating it as a list
so as you see here right the the
original JSON had name and then the name
of the repo that I'm creating this is
name you know I'm creating a list so I
don't need to put quotes here but this
is
this is the name of the repo that I'm
going to create and then this execute
the command now as you can see here I'm
doing a post to the endpoint now the
endpoint may have additional like you
know you can build URLs depending on
what you want to do
I am authenticating if this was an open
API call I wouldn't have to authenticate
it will just be open and that's it I'm
submitting the body so the body is this
piece over here but I'm submitting a
list which I'm telling it to encode as
JSON so this actually does the encoding
for me I don't have to do it myself
what do we get back when we use HTT
so we we you know you can so what I did
here is I actually I executed the
postcode sorry but I actually assigned
it to this create repo object but if we
inspect that create repo object there's
a lot of things that are in there so it
the object gets back its is a list and
it has all of the metadata from your
headers it has the body of your response
it has all of the associated stuff from
the API response so as you can see here
I got the 201 response which means that
it was successful you can actually look
at this content but this is actually in
RAW format as you see it's a bunch of
bytes so there's a couple of ways to
look at this if I actually want to see
the response like the contents of the
response I used the content function on
on the object that I created and then I
can I can see it as a text but if I just
do content create repo it's gonna
default as a list so this and this are
the same it's just one as a list when is
shown as a JSON object there you know
and now I create I with our I created a
github repository now why is this
important because I'm actually executing
instructions against another system so I
can create stuff programmatically use
these api's that are well designed and
well constructed and enabling it to my
workflow aha there's one gotcha here a
lot of times API responses are are they
come back in multiple pages so you
actually have to paginate and you have
to build some code that you know reads
the response you are actually getting
some
sometimes the header tells you how many
things you get back so for example if
the API is restricted and you're pulling
back a lot of information you make you
know the whole thing might be a hundred
thousand objects but your API may let me
do two 200 so guess what you're gonna
have to loop right you're gonna have to
figure out okay I'm trying to get a
hundred thousand objects I only can do
two hundred at a time you know maybe the
our API if you pay it gives you bigger
bandwidth whatever but the point is you
have to paginate through this so a
couple of gotchas the other thing is
even though JSON the json light object
works really well if you have a lot of
nested nests in it you still have to
kind of you know so this is some code I
wrote a long time ago I wrote a package
to pull data from the meetup.com API you
know cuz of meetup stuff that we do I
wrote this like four years ago
it is using JSON light but as you can
see you know I'm kind of using L apply
and I'm nesting and blah blah blah blah
the Our Lady's team actually just wrote
a and I called my package meetup are
it's actually on github it's on a cran
our ladies wrote it also I made up our
package which allows you to interface
with the meetup comm but they did have
much more elegantly they're using purr
and they're using Tibble and all these
sorts of things and and and this stuff
over here is taking the JSON object and
converting into a data frame all right
what I want to end up here is well why
is this important so I work for
Microsoft right and we have a lot of a
lot of great tools a lot of API is a lot
of SDKs that allow you to do stuff on
the cloud programmatically not just you
know a so this is the point click way
right you you log into Azure or any
other cloud provider and you do stuff
manually programmatically there's
command-line tools which are usually a
wrapper around an API SDKs which most
likely are not native to are a lot of
them are in Python but there is also a
REST API so there's this project called
cloudy our project which has a whole
slew of packages for our that allow you
to interface with their different cloud
providers and you know rather than you
defining the JSON object it does all
that abstraction for you
so there's one called a Gerar this is
actually fairly new this was published
maybe about two months ago
and it has a lot of different things so
it can do authentication it can do
storage it can do key vaults I can do
virtual machines and stuff like that the
important thing is down here it's really
not it's not still not yet intended to
support all of azor so for example we
saw an API an example Rafi was talking
about the Google API for text analytics
so we have one in Asscher
if you wanted to interface cognitive
services you would actually need to
create a rest I like a full and rest API
call but you can use HTT you know how to
construct the JSON object last you know
Microsoft has put a lot of investment
into our Microsoft acquired revolution
analytics many years ago Microsoft is
putting a lot of stuff out in the art
and the art community and open sourcing
a lot of these tools there's a new API a
new tool for the Azure machine learning
services coming up but there is a
website called if you search for our
developer's guide to azure it'll show
you all of the services that are kind of
our native which are which would just
work greatly with with stuff thanks a
lot
[Applause]